-Congratulations on your haircut
in the movie.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, yeah.
They were like,
"We have a wig for you."
I was like, "Wigs?
I got my own."
-Did you -- Now, did you?
-No, that was my hair.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I was watching saying,
"That looks really good."
And you've got
a great head of hair
that I feel like can also look
awful as evidenced by that,
but that's great.
-It's called a period piece.
-No, I actually remember going
up to Kathryn Bigelow,
who is one of the greatest
directors ever.
And she was like,
"Yeah, just pull the hair down.
It's kind of the style." And I
was like, "Yeah, yeah, totally."
And I kept trying to sneak it
back for the scene.
I wanted to do a lot of like --
"You know, Your Honor."
And she's like "No, no, no.
It's not how they wore it."
And I was like,
"Okay, I'll put it back."
-Yeah. It's so weird to think
that there was just a time
where everybody was totally fine
with like just hair.
Yeah, just like just resting
there your whole day,
a big old --
big old fat piece of hair.
-Just a nation of, like, skater
kids being like,
"Hey I'm also a lawyer."
You know?
-And did you know --
so this is --
You mentioned Oscar winner
Kathryn Bigelow directed and --
-I thought you
were talking about me.
I was like, "Oscar winner?
Let's not jump the gun.
I'm feeling pretty good."
The hair will win.
-The hair will win, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Did you know much about
these Detroit riots?
-I had heard about it.
I had heard a little bit about
it, but nothing in detail.
And it's unlike anything else
I've seen.
To say it's the best movie
I've seen in a long time
is such an understatement
because it's almost --
When I came out of the
screening, this girl was like,
"You know, people are talking
about virtual reality.
That is virtual reality."
And that's what it is.
You're immersed in this movie
in a way that when it ends,
you're like,
"What just happened?"
You were in some weird time
portal and it's --
It should be
a mandatory screening.
Everybody should see it just
to see what it was.
-Fantastic.
Congratulations on it.
-Thank you.
-And obviously,
that's "Detroit."
When we first met,
we're both Red Sox fans.
-In Detroit.
-Met in Detroit.
We're Red Sox fans.
You're from Massachusetts.
I'm from New Hampshire.
-That's true.
-Now as someone
from Massachusetts,
do you think it's okay that
somebody from New Hampshire is
also a Red Sox fan?
Do you count us?
-Yeah, but, like, you're
like our J.V. squad of fans.
-Yeah, okay, gotcha.
-Yeah, it's like we ride
in the bus
and you guys ride in the cars
behind the bus.
-That sounds about right.
-Yeah, you're like,
"Go, Boston Red Sox fans."
We're like, "Thanks, guys."
-And yet neither of us --
we are both without accents.
-It's true.
-Did you have to get rid of one?
-No.
-Yeah.
-No, I grew up in Newton, Mass.,
which is the least street place,
I think,
in the suburbs of Boston.
-I should point out,
to the people in actual Boston,
you are the J.V.
-That's right.
-Newton is to like Southie what
New Hampshire is to Newton.
-Oh, yeah.
Right now some guy's going,
"Is he giving that New Hampshire
kid a hard time?
I'll give you a hard time,
Newton."
That's what they're saying
right now.
-So you have a Boston accent?
You can do one.
-Yeah, I can dust it off
any time.
-Yeah.
-Usually a couple drinks helps.
-Yeah, it does.
-Or it doesn't even help.
It just forces its way in.
-Yeah, exactly.
-People are like,
"Oh, when he has drinks,
he does the Boston accent."
It's like,
"No, it's happening now."
-You also -- something else we
have in common.
You have a couple -- You have
two kids now, two girls.
-Yeah, we're multiplying.
-Beautiful girls.
This is interesting to me,
because I'm on the first one.
I've heard you have issues with
the baby products industry.
-You heard from who?
-I've heard --
Look, I've read
some negative Yelp reviews
that are very much
in your voice.
-That's what it is. Oh, good.
At least you've been tracking.
No, it's so funny,
you find yourself --
because it's the most amazing
thing in the world,
but you also feel like
you're on duty,
so you feel kind of stressed out
as far as --
You want it to be perfect.
And when they're really young,
little things drove me insane.
Like wet wipes.
Does anybody have kids?
Nobody has ever had a kid?
-No.
There's these little bags of
wet wipes that you pull out,
and you wipe bums,
but the problem is,
you never pull out one.
They're, like, bunched in 200.
-Yeah.
-So you're holding a kid
that's like seven days old
and the first thing she's seeing
is this giant person
being like...
[ Growling ]
[ Laughter ]
Like, throwing this thing
and, like, trying to get
one wet wipe out.
The baby's like,
"This is the worst."
Emily's like, "What's going on?"
I'm like, "I'm just terrifying
the child, it's fine."
And then just last week,
my youngest daughter
got a onesie
that had color-coded buttons.
And I had to take a knee.
It was like an emotional moment.
I went, "Thank you
whoever invented this."
-Oh, yeah.
Like, when a kid's moving
around, you're like,
"Where's the button go?"
And then my kid
gets up like this,
and her shirt's like that.
-There are times where my wife
will be in the other room
and can hear --
I'm not even saying anything.
She can just feel frustration
coming.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Like, is everything all right?
I'm like, "It's not going great
with the onesie right now."
-That's nice.
At least you explain it.
I just go, "Yeah!"
-Yeah.
-"Is everything all right?"
"Yeah!"
-When you walk over
and there's a new childproof
lock on something,
and it's the first time
you've seen it.
And you get over and like you
immediately get flop sweat,
because you're, like,
"I have do be an adult."
-And then "Mission: Impossible"
starts playing.
It's like -- [ Imitating
"Mission: Impossible" theme ]
-Because you're like, "I need to
be able to figure this out
in 20 seconds, or else I'm going
to be shamed for the next year."
-But you're also going up to it
with a task
because your wife will be like,
"Hey, can you go down
and grab that thing?"
You're like, "Yeah, yeah,
totally. Oh, my God.
Oh, my God,
do you pull it then push it?
Do you talk to it then pull it?"
Do you have to play "Twinkle,
Twinkle" and then it opens?
How does it happen?
How does it work?
-Your beautiful wife,
Emily Blunt,
she's in a film
that you wrote and directed.
-Yes.
-So that's very exciting.
-That's what this beard's for,
yes.
It's not just depression.
-It's a good beard, though.
-Thank you.
-That's not a depression beard,
because it's like very --
It's nice and, like, trimmed.
-Thank you, yes.
I wrote a script.
I rewrote a script these guys
wrote, that it was great.
And I'm directing now.
And the best compliment
of my entire career
is when she actually read it
just to read it for me.
And then she said, "Would you
ever let me be in the movie?"
-That's great.
-And I took a knee again.
And she's like, "What is this
taking a knee thing?
Why are you getting so
emotional?"
And I'm like, "One sec!"